-My first guest is a Golden
Globe and Grammy-nominated
artist and actor who you can see
as a coach on "The Voice,"
which airs Mondays and Tuesdays
on NBC.
And you can see him in
the new movie "Chaos Walking,"
which is in theaters Friday.
Here is Nick Jonas.
Yeah!
-Yay!
-You were fantastic, buddy.
You were fantastic.
-Thank you.
-I watched from home.
I was, like, rooting for you.
I go, "Oh, my gosh."
The video was my fave.
I love the tonal sketch.
And I love the two new jams,
the two new songs.
"Spaceman" is -- I loved.
I didn't hear --
I didn't know the other new one.
-It hasn't been released yet.
That's what I'm saying.
I kind of mentioned it
in the monologue,
but I was thinking it's been
a full year to the day,
the exact day,
since my last live performance.
So, I was just like, "Let's just
keep it really simple --
host and be a musical guest
and premiere two new songs."
I mean, why not?
-Did you get nervous
coming down the steps?
I thought that's always one of
my most nerve-racking moments.
-Yeah, so, I guess
one of the newest traditions
is the hosts writing a note
to each other.
-Really?
-Which I had just become hip to
'cause I saw Regina King
post about it.
And then Regé-Jean posted that
they had each written a note
to each other.
And so, you know,
I wrote mine to Maya Rudolph,
who just got announced
as the next host.
And then, what they do is, they
take it from your dressing room
and put it right on the door
before you walk out.
So you've got, you know,
all these cool notes
from all the other hosts,
and the last,
I think, six, seven hosts
just wishing each other
good luck,
but it feels like a mutual --
sort of, like,
"Hey, take a deep breath.
Don't trip down the stairs.
Take your time on the monologue
and do your thing."
It was really special.
-Here's the vinyl right here.
This is the --
March 12th, it comes out.
-Mm.
-"Spaceman."
Where did you shoot this?
I'm assuming -- I know you.
Did you go to space?
Were you on Mars?
-We went to Mars.
-Yeah, I figured.
-Yeah, Elon Musk
funded the whole thing.
-I knew it.
-It was the most expensive
album photo shoot ever.
-And with COVID and everything,
can you imagine?
-Yeah, I think it was just
an extra wealthy shoot.
But, basically,
we went out to Barstow.
Apparently, there was a volcano
there at one point.
And now
there's this volcanic rock --
it's like a crater --
which, you know,
is both really cool,
but, also, very dangerous.
I still have battle scars
from all over my hands
from falling and shredding
my hands on this volcanic rock.
-I mean, that lava.
-It looked really cool, so...
-No, the coolest shot.
-...I don't really care,
you know?
You know, I sort of
started writing this record
back in July.
My wife was over in Germany,
finishing up this little movie
called "The Matrix."
And...
[ Chuckles ]
And I was like, "You know,
I feel very disconnected
from the world, first of all,
and now my person."
-Yeah.
-And I just dug in writing it
with Greg Kurstin and Mozella.
Within a couple of days,
I was like, "Oh, this is --
this is a solo album."
Then a few days later,
I was like,
"This is a --
a kind of like themed album."
You know, giving --
This idea that
we've all had this year now --
I loved the thing with John,
by the way.
It was great.
-Ah.
-But this year of being sort of
disconnected from reality,
disconnected from the world,
and feeling like
we're on our own planet.
And, you know, also,
obviously missing her
at that time, as well,
and then reconnecting with her.
And then the main theme
from this album, I think,
is, more than anything,
is just about hopefulness
for the future
and seeing a brighter day ahead.
-Ah, we need that now,
more than ever, buddy.
I wanted to ask you
about something
that you called
the Jonas Blessing.
Now, can --
-Mm.
-...can you --
can you first explain
to everyone what it is --
who don't know?
-Sure. I'd be happy to.
I mean, it's quite simple,
you know?
In reality,
what happened is that,
when the brothers
got back together --
we went on tour
on the Happiness Begins Tour
back in 2019 --
we had a number of athletes,
high-performing athletes,
come out to see shows.
So, the first was
Cody Bellinger,
who then went on to win
the World Series
with the Dodgers, right?
-Amazing.
-We had Patrick Mahomes,
who, in the 2020 Super Bowl,
won the Super Bowl
with the Kansas City Chiefs.
-Wow.
-He came to a show in K.C.
And then Lewis Hamilton, who
surpassed the all-time record...
-Oh, yeah.
-He went on to,
after he came to a show,
to do that.
So, basically, we established,
and I think it was really me
more than the brothers --
I saw the trend.
I was saying...
-You think?
-..."We're gonna have to start
charging these athletes.
If they want the Jonas Blessing,
to come to a show
and then
go on to win a championship,
they're gonna have to pay up."
-Yeah.
-You know?
You think that it was you
that came up with it,
but it might have been --
it might have been someone else?
-Yeah.
Little known fact, too, Jimmy,
is that Tom Brady --
we actually did a private,
COVID-safe show for Tom Brady
before the Super Bowl,
and that's why.
-[ Laughs ] There you go.
That's a -- That's a juicy --
That's the story
I'm talking about.
That's what I -- That's what I
wanted to get to, of course.
I want to talk about
your new movie, "Chaos Walking."
Tell us every--
-Yes.
-Tell everyone what this
is about and who you play.
It's a good -- great cast.
-Well, you know, I was happy
to give these other actors,
these scrubs, these newbies
a shot in this movie.
-Oh.
-Tom Holland, Daisy Ridley.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, my God.
-You know, Mads Mikkelsen.
No one's ever heard of them.
Cynthia Erivo.
So, yeah. I don't know.
I was just happy to be there.
With a cast like that,
it was -- it was unbelievable.
-Doug Liman directing.
-Doug Liman directing --
the legend that he is.
It's a -- It's a wild ride,
you know?
It's a dystopian world where
there's this settlement of men
who --
basically, something happened.
I don't want
to give too much away.
But all of their thoughts
and visions in their head
are heard and seen
in an orb around them.
So, as you can imagine,
that creates some problems.
-I want to --
I also want to talk about --
you returned as a coach on
"The Voice,"
and people love this.
This is your second season
as a coach.
And I have a theory already.
I feel like, the first season,
I think they gave you
a good kind of ribbing.
They kind of --
They kind of said, like,
"Oh, this newbie, this guy."
And then...
-Yeah.
-And now you're back,
and you're like,
"I know --
I know how to play this game.
Let's go.
You want to go, Blake?"
-Well, that's the thing.
That first year
definitely is like
you're the new kid at school.
You know?
-Yeah.
-But I came out swinging
this time.
You know, I was like,
"I'm not gonna feel things out."
-Yeah.
-"I'm gonna go
straight for the jugular."
-Good.
-And it was --
first day of blind auditions,
which actually aired
last night...
-It was great.
-The second night is tonight,
probably just aired.
...is --
you know, it's a lot of fun.
It's like Kelly is
the three of our, like, sister.
And we're all, you know,
just having fun
and giving each other
the necessary amount of crap.
And...
-Yeah.
-You know, I'm just trying
to keep Blake humble.
-[ Chuckles ] How --
-You know, he's won seven times,
he thinks that he's
the Tom Brady of "The Voice,"
and he needs to calm down.
-[ Chuckles ]
You'll never do it.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Nick Jonas in
the new season of "The Voice."
Take a look at this.
-I didn't know you got blocked.
I didn't even realize
you got blocked.
-Nor did I.
-You see what he's done, Nick?
When Kelly blocked Blake...
-Mm-hmm.
-...he set you up making
you think that he was here
looking out for your interests.
-Wait. Unless you did it.
-It can only be the person
that went before you, Nick.
-Yes. Okay. So it was you.
-No, that's not true!
That's not -- That --
I didn't -- What?!
-Do you want to be
on a liar's team?
-Blake always lies about it,
too.
-If I did, it was an accident.
I was trying to --
-Oh, my gosh!
-Unbelievable.
-"It was an accident."
-"If I did..."
-He could have picked any of us
to block.
-He must be that afraid
of me as a coach.
-Who did he pick?
-Nick Jonas, everybody.
"The Voice" --
blind auditions continue
next Monday at 8:00
and Tuesday at 9:00 p.m. on NBC.
Nick, we always ask you
to do something
and play a game or something.
Do you -- Would you mind?
-I would love to.
I was actually thinking,
"This interview is so boring.
Let's just play a game already."
-More with Nick Jonas
when we come back. Stick around.